good news everyone arm processors are
coming to gke
when using arm with gke sure you can
start from scratch and create a new gk
cluster with arm nodes
but many of you are already using gke so
let's walk through how you can also add
new node pools with arm processors to an
existing gke cluster with x86 nodes
so we'll start with this single gke
cluster with one node pool running x86
chips
this is our default node pool
running vms from the e2 machine family
this family is backed by amd and intel
processors both x86 architecture
[Music]
we can verify this by running a simple
go app that uses the runtime package in
the go standard library
to read and return the underlying
runtime architecture
in our case amd 64 for x86
or arm 64 for arm
[Music]
there's already one replica of an x86
version of this app running behind the
kubernetes service
so let's send a request to this external
ip for the kubernetes service
we can see in the response that the
current architecture is amd64 or x86
this is our current application our one
pod replica
but now comes a tricky part what if
you're new to arm what does one do to
get a workload not just running on arm
processors but in a container in a
kubernetes cluster
let's walk through building this same
app but for arm
the first thing to notice is the gorch
or go architecture environment variable
we are now specifying arm64 in this
valley
this tells the go compiler what
architecture we want to build for
the second thing to notice is that we
are using a multi-stage build which is
typically a best practice for building
lean containers
we were also doing this in the x86
version
but the thing to note here is that we
are specifying a different arm 64 base
image in our second stage
and then we copy over the go binary
we've built
[Music]
so we'll build this container image
using this docker file and push it to
artifact registry
[Music]
with the container image now built now
we have to actually make sure that we
have arm vms ready to run our app
[Music]
you'll notice that we'll still be using
the standard g-cloud command to add a
node pool to our cluster
but this time we're specifying t2avms
the vms running arm processors
and now that our nodepool creation has
completed we can see that we have side
by side our default pool running e2 vms
and our arm pool running t2a vms
again the great part about this in gke
is that if we are trying to slowly and
safely migrate to arm from x86 we can
run the infrastructure for each
architecture simultaneously
we can also deploy this arm app behind
the same kubernetes service that exposes
our x86 app
this allows us to serve requests using
both the x86 and arm versions of our
applications so that we can put into
practice safe patterns like canary
deployments
[Music]
now let's deploy our rmap
we're going to use customize to deploy
the new version of our app
if you're not familiar with it this tool
allows us to have a base configuration
of yaml and patch specific changes
separately
this gives us an easy way to see what
we're changing when we deploy the arm
version of this app
the first
is a matching toleration for the taint
that we applied to the node pool earlier
we can see that the key and the value
are the same as the taint that we had
when we created the node pool
the second
is the new container image that we just
built
okay now let's actually deploy our app
we'll note here that customize is
integrated into coop ctl and the way
we'll use it is we'll write coupsey tail
apply k and we'll specify where the
files we just went over are
we see our arm deployment has now been
created and if we get our pods in
service we can see that we have one pod
of each version
all behind the same service
now let's send some traffic to our
kubernetes service again
[Music]
as you can see here both the x86 and arm
replicas are successfully running in our
cluster exposed by the same service and
responding to traffic
we did it we are now successfully using
our arm nodes in gke
[Music]
but before we go one thing we do want to
address is the concern that with this
example you now might be maintaining two
different build processes one for x86
and one for arm
to keep a single consistent build
process
let's take a look at building a
multi-architecture image
[Music]
in this new docker file that we have
notice that we are still performing a
multi-stage build like we did earlier
only now we don't need to use an arm
base image in the second stage
[Music]
what's even cooler is that container
runtimes are aware enough to read the
manifest referencing the images built
and pull the right image for its
architecture
so now let's deploy this
multi-architecture app
[Music]
in this scenario we deployed multiple
replicas of this multi-architecture app
and we can see
that some of them get scheduled to arm
nodes
and some of them get scheduled to x86
nodes
[Music]
this helps us keep a single and
consistent build process
of course there is the caveat that you
may not be able to take the simpler
approach if your app is using
platform-specific functionality or the
language you're using might not be as
friendly to cross-compilation like our
go app
either way
hopefully this introduction got you
excited about learning more about
potentially building for arm and using
gke support for arm nodes to run your
applications
my name is anthony bouchon developer
relations engineer here at google thank
you for spending this time with me to
learn more and dig deeper check out the
links in the description we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you